Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
"Alguien debe haber estado
diciendo mentiras sobre Josef K.
Él sabía que no había hecho nada malo,
pero una mañana, fue detenido".
Así comienza "El Juicio"
una de las novelas más conocidas
del autor Franz Kafka.
K, el protagonista, es detenido porque sí
y obligado a pasar
por un proceso desconcertante
donde ni la causa de su detención,
ni la naturaleza
de los procesos judiciales
son claros para él.
Este tipo de escenario se considera
tan característico de la obra de Kafka
que los académicos dieron
con una nueva palabra para él.
Kafkiano entró en la lengua vernácula para
describir lo innecesariamente complicado
y las experiencias frustrantes,
como ser forzados a desplazarse
por laberintos de burocracia.
¿Pero estar pie en una larga cola
para llenar el papeleo confuso
realmente captura la riqueza
de la visión de Kafka?
Más allá de un uso ocasional de
la palabra, ¿qué hace algo kafkiano?
Las historias de Franz Kafka en efecto,
se ocupan de muchos aspectos mundanos
y absurdos de la burocracia moderna,
dibujando en parte su experiencia
de trabajar como un empleado de seguros
en Praga de principios del siglo XX.
Muchos de sus protagonistas
son trabajadores de oficina
obligados a luchar a través
de una red de obstáculos
con el fin de lograr sus objetivos,
y, a menudo todo el proceso
resulta ser tan desorientador e ilógico
que el éxito se vuelve
inútil en primer lugar.
Por ejemplo,
en la breve historia, "Poseidón"
el dios griego antiguo es un ejecutivo
tan inundado con el papeleo
que nunca ha tenido tiempo
para explorar sus dominios bajo el agua.
La broma aquí es que ni siquiera un dios
puede manejar la cantidad de papeleo
exigido por el lugar de trabajo moderno.
Pero la razón por la que está diciendo.
No está dispuesto a delegar
ninguno de los trabajos
debido a que considera a todos
los demás indignos de la tarea.
El Poseidón de Kafka es un prisionero
de su propio ego.
Esta sencilla historia
contiene todos los elementos
que hacen que un escenario sea
verdaderamente kafkiano.
No es lo absurdo de
la burocracia por sí sola,
sino la ironía del razonamiento circular
del personaje en reacción a él
que es un emblema
de la escritura de Kafka.
Sus historias tragicómicas son una forma
de mitología de la era industrial moderna,
empleando una lógica de sueño
para explorar las relaciones
entre los sistemas de poder arbitrario
y los individuos atrapados en ellos.
Tomemos, por ejemplo, el más famoso
cuento de Kafka, "La metamorfosis".
Cuando Gregorio Samsa despierta
una mañana se encuentra transformado
en un insecto gigante,
su mayor preocupación es
que tiene que llegar a trabajar a tiempo.
Por supuesto, resulta imposible.
No fue solo el reino autoritario del
lugar de trabajo lo que inspiró Kafka.
Algunas de las luchas de sus
protagonistas vienen desde dentro.
La corta historia, "Un artista del hambre"
describe un artista de circo cuyo acto
consiste en ayunos prolongados.
Está molesto porque el maestro de circo
limita a estos 40 días,
creyendo que esto le impide alcanzar
la grandeza de su arte.
Pero cuando su acto pierde popularidad,
se le deja libre para dejarse morir.
El giro viene cuando yace moribundo
en el anonimato,
lamentablemente admitiendo
que su arte siempre ha sido un fraude.
Él no ayunó por la fuerza de su voluntad,
sino simplemente porque nunca
encontró una comida que le gustara.
Incluso en "El juicio"
que parece concentrarse
directamente en la burocracia,
las leyes vagas
y los procedimientos desconcertantes
apuntan a algo mucho más siniestro:
el terrible momento de un
sistema legal que resulta imparable,
incluso para los funcionarios
supuestamente poderosos.
Este es un sistema
que no sirve a la justicia,
pero cuya única función
es la de perpetuarse.
Lo que la teórica política Hannah Arendt,
escribiendo años después
de la muerte de Kafka,
llamaría "tiranía sin tirano".
Acompañando la desolación
de las historias de Kafka,
hay una gran cantidad de humor
enraizado en la lógica absurda
de las situaciones descritas.
Así, por un lado, es fácil reconocer
lo kafkiano en el mundo actual.
Nos basamos en sistemas de administración
cada vez más complicados
con consecuencias reales sobre
todos los aspectos de nuestras vidas.
Y encontramos que cada palabra nuestra
es juzgada por gente que no podemos ver
de acuerdo con las reglas
que no conocemos.
Por otro lado, al ajustar
nuestra atención sobre lo absurdo,
Kafka también refleja nuestros defectos
sobre nosotros mismos.
Al hacerlo, nos recuerda que el mundo
en que vivimos es uno que creamos,
y que tenemos el poder
de cambiar para mejor.